[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis schönen guten Abend im Sport
wird auf den Fußball geschaut mit
Norbert König klar vor der WM guten
Abend die Staaten Ring um eine
Begrenzung der Erderwärmung kommen aber
nicht wirklich voran eines unserer
Themen
Endspurt in Ägypten der Weltklimagipfel
den Sharm el Sheikh geht in die
entscheidende Phase doch trotz
dringender Appelle ist eine Einigung
noch nicht in Sicht
Urteil in den Niederlanden nach den
Abschuss des Passagierflugzeugs mh17 mit
298 Toten wurden heute drei Angeklagte
schuldig gesprochen
und Ankunft in Katar nach einem eher
schwachen Auftritt gegen Oman gestern
Abend ist die deutsche
Fußballnationalmannschaft am Mittag in
ihrem WM-Quartier eingetroffen
[Musik]
morgen soll die Weltklimakonferenz zu
Ende gehen aber es sieht nach einer
Verlängerung aus dennoch gibt es zu
viele Streitpunkte und offene Fragen
zwischen den rund 200 Ländern die
Staatengemeinschaft hat sich 2015 in
Pariser Abkommen vorgenommen die
Erderwärmung zu begrenzen möglichst auf
maximal 1,5 Grad Celsius im Vergleich
zur vorindustriellen Zeit dafür müssen
die Vertragsstaaten den Ausstoß von
Treibhausgasen radikal reduzieren aber
an der Umsetzung hapert es und auch an
der Frage wie die hilfsversprechen an
die ärmeren Länder umgesetzt werden
können aus Sharm el Sheikh Elisa
justice Gerechtigkeit fordern diese
klimaaktivisten und um Gerechtigkeit und
Verantwortung bringen sie auch bei den
Verhandlungen auf dieser Klimakonferenz
besonders bei der Finanzierung von
Klimaschäden doch eine Einigung ist noch
nicht in Sicht der UNO-Generalsekretär
macht Druck bei Youtube ich bin hier um
alle Parteien dazu aufzurufen sich der
größten Herausforderung der Menschheit
zu stellen
die armen Länder fordern finanzielle
Unterstützung für die Schäden die der
Klimawandel schon jetzt bei ihnen
anrichtet Annalena baerbock sieht auch
Deutschland da in der Verantwortung es
stimmt wir in Europa und in Nordamerika
als Industriestaaten tragen mit unserem
Fossil aufgebauten Wohlstand die
Verantwortung für die Klimaschäden der
jüngeren Vergangenheit und auch die
meisten der Gegenwart aber alle großen
Emittenten von heute tragen die
Verantwortung für die Klimaschäden der
Zukunft ein Seitenhieb auf China das
zwar einen geldhöpf fordert jedoch nicht
einzahlen will viele der Industrie-
Deutschland hat hier eine ganz besondere
Rolle denn sie wurde beauftragt von der
ägyptischen Präsidentschaft hier eine
Einigung zu bringen und das bedeutet nun
dass ein Entschluss her muss der
natürlich dem Bedürfnissen der ärmsten
verletzlichsten Staaten entgegenkommt
offiziell bricht nun die letzte Nacht an
doch alle erwarten dass diese
Klimakonferenz in die Verlängerung gehen
wird
es scheint also festgefahren wie die
Hirscher ist denn trotzdem mit konkreten
Ergebnissen zu rechnen bei dieser
Konferenz
also noch ist hier gar nicht sicher das
Problem ist dass es bislang kein Entwurf
für ein Abschlusspapier gibt das ist
sehr unüblich für den Vorabend vor dem
großen Finale wenn es morgen zu Ende
sein sollte das heißt man kann nicht
ablesen schwarz auf weiß wo diese
Konferenz in den einzelnen
verhandlungskapiteln steht das ist die
Lage Außenministerin Werbung hat hier
heute auch gesagt diese Konferenz sei
die schwierigste und die wichtigste
Konferenz angesichts des Klimawandels in
dem die Welt sich gerade befindet das
zeigt der politische Druck der auf
dieser Konferenz jetzt liegt aus den
Verhandlungen selbst ist zu hören das
ist schon ein Erfolg wäre wenn man nicht
hinter die Ergebnisse vorheriger
Klimakonferenzen zurückfallen würde das
heißt gesucht wird hier jetzt in Ägypten
der kleinste kleinste gemeinsame Nenner
ist jetzt alles schlecht nein das hat
diese Woche ja auch Hoffnung schon mal
gegeben der Auftritt ist brasilianischen
Präsidenten Lula für mehr Schutz der
Regenwälder auch dass die USA und China
wieder miteinander sprechen
wird am Ende weiß man nicht nur 1 steht
schon fest die Ägypter haben sich hier
als Leitung dieser Konferenz keinen
guten Namen gemacht denn sonst gab es
jetzt ein Entwurf und alle wüssten mehr
danke für diese Einschätzung wie die
knapp sechs Jahre Haft wegen der
rechtsextremen Drohschreiben NSU 2.0 so
das Urteil des Landgerichts Frankfurt am
Main gegen Alexander m über Jahre hatte
er Todesdrohungen und rassistische
Beleidigungen an Politikerin
JournalistInnen Personen des
öffentlichen Lebens geschickt mit dem
Absender NSU 2.0 spielte er dabei auf
die Neonazi Terrorgruppe NSU an auch
nach dem Prozess bleibt aber offen wie
genau Alexander Emma die Daten der
Betroffenen kam Markus weishofer
Heil Hitler ihr scheiß-aktivistinnen wir
legen euch alle um die großschreiben das
selbsternannten NSU 2.0 sind Zeilen
voller Hass und er hat sie noch
Überzeugung der Richter verschickt
Alexander m ein Arbeitsloser
IT-Techniker vor bestraft das Urteil
fünf Jahre und 10 Monate Haft unter
anderem wegen Bedrohung Beleidigung und
Volksverhetzung Sprache könne genauso
verletztend sein wie ein körperlicher
Angriff so das Gericht die Betroffenen
heute erleichtert aber nur teilweise von
diesem Urteil geht auf jeden Fall eine
wichtige Signalwirkung für all
diejenigen in diesem Land aus die Hass
und Hetze ausgesetzt sind aber die
zentralen Fragen die uns jetzt
beschäftigt haben zu den einzelnen
Abfragen durch Polizeibeamtin Polizei
Revieren ist nach wie vor ungeklärt die
Empfänger der großschreiben glauben
nicht dass Alexander m ein Einzel Täter
gewesen sei sie vermuten weitere Helfer
auch bei der Polizei klar ist die Daten
wurden unter anderem in einem
Frankfurter Revier abgerufen und bei den
Ermittlungen kam raus dass einige
Polizisten einer rassistischen
chatgruppe waren dass sie aber Alexander
ihm geholfen haben dieser Verdacht
konnte nicht erhärtet werden wie der
Täter genau an die Daten kam unklar für
die Richter war diese Frage aber nicht
entscheidend das Gericht hat sehr
schlüssig sehr nachvollziehbar
aufgezeigt dass alle drohscheiben exakt
dieselbe Handschrift getragen haben also
aus einem Guss waren und das haben sie
an verschiedenen kleinen Indizien
festgemacht von daher ist die These des
Gerichts dass wir es hier mit einem
Einzeltäter was die Drohschreiben
anbelangt zu tun haben sehr
nachvollziehbar in Frankfurt ist der
Prozess NSU 2.0 vorerst juristisch
abgeschlossen Experten und Betroffene
fordern dennoch weitere Aufklärung vor
allem zur Rolle der hessischen Polizei
Kindern wird sexualisierte Gewalt vor
allem von Familienmitgliedern oder von
Menschen aus ihrem sozialen Umfeld
angetan um darauf aufmerksam zu machen
und Kinder besser zu schützen haben
Bundesfamilienministerin Paulus und die
Missbrauchsbeauftragte Klaus heute eine
Kampagne gestartet darüber berichtet
wird das spielkamann
alles sagen immer die nicht mit Fremden
mit
[Musik]
und wenn es gar kein Fremder ist es ist
ein dunkles Kapitel Missbrauch findet
meist im familiären Umfeld statt das
Ambiente der heutigen Pressekonferenz
angelehnt an eine
Wohnzimmer-Atmosphäre und dann stellen
Sie sich bitte vor dass es hier nicht
immer so gemütlich zugeht in diesem
Wohnzimmer
dass der Schein drückt
stellen Sie sich vor dieses Wohnzimmer
ist ein Tatort
hier an einem eigentlich sicheren Ort
geschieht sexuelle Gewalt
2021 meldet die polizeiliche
Kriminalstatistik
15.500 Fälle von sexuellem
Kindesmissbrauch das Dunkelfeld ungleich
größer umso wichtiger sei es bei einem
Verdacht nicht wegzuschauen erst wenn
wir Missbrauch auch in unserem direkten
Umfeld für möglich halten in unserer
Familie in der Nachbarschaft im
Freundeskreis erst dann werden wir uns
damit auseinandersetzen was wir tun
könnten wenn wir uns Gedanken wenn wir
uns Sorgen um ein Kind machen man sollte
das Gespräch suchen und neben dem Hilfe
Telefon gebe es bundesweit
Fachberatungsstellen dieser und andere
Spots die nun regelmäßig ausgestrahlt
werden sind eine Mahnung an alle schieb
den Gedanken nicht weg
jetzt sind die Ukraine dort fehlt es
nach gezielten russischen Angriffen
vielerorts an Wasser und Strom die EU
will deshalb ihre winterhilfeausweiten
aktuell liefert sie im Notunterkünfte
Stromgeneratoren Nahrungsmittel und
Medizin Dinge die jederzeit überall
gebraucht werden könnten Nina kuschelgin
berichtet
heute morgen in der Industriestadt nipro
ganz normaler Berufsverkehr dann der
Einschlag
gleich in mehreren Städten soll es heute
laut der Ukraine Angriffe gegeben haben
die heftigsten in libro aber auch hier
die Hafenstadt Odessa und Willen Jans
sollen getroffen worden sein dort
starben beim Einschlag in ein Wohnhaus
mehrere Menschen viele wurden verletzt
in Polen geht die Spurensuche nach dem
Raketeneinschlag weiter wahrscheinlich
bleibt dass eine ukrainische
Flugabwehrrakete irrtümlich das Land
getroffen hat die Ukraine bezweifelt das
weiter Präsident selensky sagte heute
auf einem Wirtschaftsforum das nun auch
ukrainische Fachleute an der
Untersuchung teilnehmen dürfen morgen
früh werden unsere Profis zur
Absturzstelle fahren
eine gute Nachricht das getreideabkommen
über das Schwarze Meer wird verlängert
um 120 Tage also auch über den Winter
darauf hat man sich unter Vermittlung
der UN und der Türkei geeinigt der
türkische Präsident Erdogan twitterte
die Ausfuhr von mehr als 11 Millionen
Tonnen Getreide und Nahrungsmitteln auf
etwa 500 Schiffen in den letzten vier
Monaten zeigt die Bedeutung dieses
Abkommens für die
Nahrungsmittelversorgung und Sicherheit
der Welt
derweil fiel in Kiew der erste Schnee
die Sorge wächst bei vielen von Tag zu
Tag mehr vor einem Winter ohne Strom
Heizung und Wasser
Wert vor acht Jahren über dem Osten der
Ukraine das Passagierflugzeug mh17
abgeschossen wer ist verantwortlich für
den Tod von 298 Menschen
drei damals hochrangige pro russische
Separatisten so ein niederländisches
Gericht heute und verurteilte sie in
Abwesenheit zu lebenslange Haft
im Juli 2014 hatte die russische Rakete
die Boeing der Malaysia Airlines über
umkämpften Gebiet in der Ostukraine
getroffen drei Stunden nach dem Start in
Amsterdam an Bord Menschen aus zehn
Ländern 4 aus Deutschland die meisten
aber aus den Niederlanden Gunna Krüger
als die Richter kommen um das Urteil zu
fällen da sitzt Pete Pluch der Sprecher
niederländischer Angehöriger mitten
unter den Zuschauern
ich werde meine Gefühle ausschalten gut
zuhören und schauen was das Urteil
bedeutet doch auch sein Bruder dessen
Frau und Sohn starben auf Flug Emma 17
für jedes Opfer wächst heute ein Baum
neben der Stadtbahn für alle wild people
Plug Recht und Gerechtigkeit
Bilder im Netz sollen dabei helfen da
fuhr ein Luftabwehrsystem aus Russland
unter die Flugroute und mit einer Rakete
weniger zurück
wenn das Gericht solche Belege von
Internetnutzern würdigt jene offenen
Quellen die dann auch die Ermittler
nutzten dann wird es helfen Standards zu
entwickeln für deren Glaubwürdigkeit
offene Quellen dazu abgehörte Gespräche
auf dieser Basis forderte die Anklage
lebenslang für diese Männer die aber in
Russland leben in Fall von zwei Russen
und einem Ukraine folgen ihnen heute die
Richter
in Anbetracht der Schwere der bewiesenen
Taten und der Höhe der Strafe ordnet das
Gericht ihre Festnahme an
russland will das Urteil prüfen eine
Auslieferung gilt als unwahrscheinlich
das weiß auch Pitch
wir Angehörigen wollten die Wahrheit
wissen wir wollten das Recht gesprochen
wird das sei passiert auch wenn auf
Schuld vorerst keine Strafe folgt
bei den mitturmwahlen in den USA haben
Umfragen einen hohen Sieg der
Republikaner erwartet doch es kam
bekanntlich anders nach uS-Medien
berichten hat die Partei von Donald
Trump jetzt im Repräsentantenhaus eine
knappe Mehrheit im Senat dagegen konnten
die Demokraten ihre Mehrheit verteidigen
führende Republikaner werfen Trump vor
mit seiner Politik der Spaltung für das
schlechte Abschneiden der Partei
verantwortlich zu sein
die Inflation ist in Großbritannien auf
über 11% gestiegen das Haushaltsloch
wächst und das Land befinde sich bereits
in einer Rezession so Finanzminister
Hand er kündigte daher eine höhere
übergewinnsteuer für Öl und
Gasunternehmen an und nicht nur besser
verdienender sollen stärker zur Kasse
gebeten werden mehr von Andreas Stamm
wer ist schuld an der Misere die Frage
an den Finanzminister auf dem Weg ins
Parlament im Gepäck Steuererhöhungen für
weite Teile der Bevölkerung Ausgaben
Kürzungen denn Pandemie und Ukraine
Krieg hätten ein 60 Milliarden Euro
Haushaltsloch gerissen wir wollen
niedrigere Steuern und einen
ausgeglichenen Haushalt der ist aber
wichtiger denn sonst frisst die
Inflation Löhne und erspart ist der
Menschen auf heimtückischer als es jede
Steuererhöhung kann
was der Finanzminister da unterschlägt
sein Vorgänger selbe Partei hatte vor
wenigen Wochen unter Jubel massive
Steuersenkungen versprochen mitten in
einer Wirtschaftskrise das Ergebnis die
Regierung Trust musste zurücktreten die
Finanzmärkte verloren das Vertrauen in
den Standort Britannien mehr als 30
Milliarden Euro so Schätzungen habe
dieses Experiment gekostet die
haushaltsnot vergrößert und viele Briten
Mythen gemacht
ich bin sehr besorgt vor allem da wir
von einer inkompetenten Regierung zur
nächsten wechseln von denen hat keiner
einer Ahnung um was es hier geht
hat sich völlig von uns Bürgern
abgekoppelt wir werden im Stich gelassen
und das macht mir Angst die
Opposition schäumt ebenfalls die
Konservativen hätten die Wirtschaft vor
die Wand gefahren unterstützung bekommen
sie von Ökonomen die eine weitere
tori-sünde als Grund benennen die
gesamte britische Volkswirtschaft ist
durch den brexit dauerhaft beschädigt
worden ohne den EU-Austritt müssten wir
wahrscheinlich nicht über einen
Sparhaushalt diskutieren
über die Gründe hat noch gestritten
werden aber eins ist unstrittig es
kommen erklärt selbst der Finanzminister
schwere Zeiten
in weiten Teilen Deutschlands gibt es
aktuell Störungen in Mobilfunknetzen
außerdem sind die Notrufnummern 110 und
112 teilweise nur eingeschränkt
erreichbar Probleme gibt es zum Beispiel
in Hamburg Bremen und baden-
in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern heute große
Erleichterung bei den Beschäftigten der
MV Werften denn es hat sich ein Käufer
gefunden für das fast fertiggestellte
Kreuzfahrtschiff global Dream nach der
Insolvenz der werfen war völlig unklar
wie es mit dem Riesen Schiff weitergeht
und vor allem mit den Arbeitsplätzen die
daran hängen bernd moselbach hat die
Details nun muss sie also doch nicht
verschrottet werden die global Dream das
ehrgeizige Projektes asiatischen
tourismuskonzerns genting der Anfang des
Jahres Insolvenz anmelden musste der
Disney Konzern hat das Schiff gekauft
die Belegschaft erleichtert
warum ist ja egal wer das Schiff kostet
die Arbeitsplätze sind erstmal so weit
denke ich mir mal auf irgendeine Art und
Weise kurzfristig erstmal gesichert
jetzt freuen sich alle dass das Schiff
fertig wird dass das hier was in Wismar
auch von den Menschen erarbeitet wurde
von unseren Kolleginnen und Kollegen
dass das dann auch tatsächlich zur
Anwendung kommt von den 1900
Beschäftigten sind nach der Insolvenz
noch 900 auf der Werft gemeinsam mit der
Meyer Werft soll das Schiff bis Ende
nächsten Jahres umgebaut werden das war
ein sehr guter Deal weil es der beste
war den wir bekommen konnten und die
Alternative gewesen wäre dass das Schiff
in der Türkei verschrottet wird Disney
will aus dem Schiff einen schwimmenden
Unterhaltungspark machen Kaufpreis
unbekannt ob das Land seine Bürgschaften
von rund 300 Millionen Euro
zurückbekommen ist noch offen
in drei Tagen beginnt die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft in Katar und
das letzte Testspiel der deutschen
Mannschaft ist ja jetzt abgehakt noch
oder das magere 1:0 gegen den Oman soll
natürlich kein Maßstab sein für die
erste Partie gegen Japan am nächsten
Mittwoch sie sind angekommen im
Gastgeberland der WM 2022 und der
Empfang war schon mal weltmeisterlich
nach der Landung in Doha ging es ins
rund 100 km entfernte Quartier im
äußersten Norden des Landes wo Sie
herzlich empfangen wurden
in diesem Luxushotel beginnt die
wm-mission die medialfall bis zum Finale
dauern soll Trainer und Team haben nur
noch sechs Tage bis zum Auftakt gegen
Japan viel Zeit um in Form und Schwung
zu kommen bleibt also nicht
in den wenigen Trainingseinheiten die
die Trainer nur haben eben auch noch mal
die wichtigen Akzente gerade im
technik-taktischen zu setzen das wird
auf jeden Fall passieren und sonst
einfach fokussiert sein und
sich darauf freuen Niklas Füllkrug
Lichtblick im letzten Test und Kollegen
wohnen weit weg von Doha in einer
Unterkunft umgeben von Meer und Wüste
Sven Voss ist auch schon in Katar das
deutsche Team lässt sich jetzt erstmal
ruhig angehen oder
ja Norbert Entspannung und Regeneration
standen heute auf dem Programm nach
Ankunft in der Abgeschiedenheit des
Wellnesshotels allzu lange ganz im
Norden von Katha auch morgen wird noch
nicht ernsthaft Fußball gespielt erst am
Samstag dann zwei Trainingseinheiten
aber einer hat morgen definitiv nicht
frei das ist der DFB-Präsident Bernd
Neuendorf der hatte ja in den
vergangenen Tagen nicht mit Kritik
gespart am Gastgeberland und auch an der
FIFA und man darf gespannt sein ob er
schon einen Schritt weiter ist mit
seiner Forderung nach einem
Entschädigungsfond für die
Hinterbliebenen der Verstorbenen
Zwangsarbeiter
danke für die aktuellen Information
Japan erster Gruppengegner der deutschen
Mannschaft hat seinen letzten Test gegen
die ebenfalls qualifizierte Auswahl
Kanadas in Doha mit eins zu zwei
verloren Yuki Soma hatte sein Team schon
in der 9 minute in Führung gebracht der
Ausgleich wenig später die Entscheidung
brachte in der Nachspielzeit ein
kurioser faul Elfmeter von Lukas
Cavallini den Torhüter Gonda noch
[Applaus]
aber auch die Japaner sagen Test egal
genau was
grau trüb regnerisch mit einer Tendenz
zum Winter es wird kälter bei uns und
Schneeflocken mischen mit wo das sagt
uns gleich Katja horneffer
Christian Sievers hat um 21.45 das heute
journal für Sie tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend wärmer und Kälte sind bei
uns in Deutschland auf Kollisionskurs
das liegt an dem Hoch über Skandinavien
und dem tief über dem Ärmelkanal schon
heute fiel der Schnee im Harz oder auch
im Erzgebirge und in der zweiten
Nachthälfte fällt dann auch Schnee im
Flachland da mischen sich Schneeflocken
unter den Regen hier zwischen
Nordfriesland und der Uckermark und auch
am alten Rand schneit etwas so jetzt
glatt auf Straßen und Gehwegen und das
ganz besonders hier im Nordosten denn da
sinken die Temperaturen auf plus zwei
bis minus drei Grad morgen über Tag gibt
es eine gegenläufige Entwicklung zum
einen kommen von Südwesten noch
Regenschauer heran die Richtung
Nordosten ziehen und gleichzeitig zieht
dieses schneeregenband aus dem Nordosten
weiter in Richtung Südwesten es erreicht
bis zum Abende etwa eine Linie Bremen
Chemnitz also glatt auf den Straßen im
Nordosten allerdings wird es strahlen
sonnig nur direkt an der Ostseeküste
gibt es einige Power und rund in Berlin
bleibt es morgen am kältesten da steigen
die Werte nicht über ein Grad hinaus
deutlich milder wird es dagegen noch mal
am Rhein mit bis zu 12 Grad winterlich
wird dann auch der Samstag danach
beruhigt sich die Lage ein bisschen
guten Abend